what was your what's the the biggest
thing or your favorite role you've done
besides American Pie what role did you
really just have fun and go I love doing
this
there are a couple I mean I I loved
playing Buffy and scary movie that was
really fun
um like especially like when I got to do
my my death scene because Keenan Ivory
Wayans really worked with me on it for a
long time we shot take after take after
take after take
so that was fun and and it was one of
the only times we got to do rehearsals
like to be on a film where you get to
have a week in rehearsals to get to like
know each other and bond and like it's
such a great experience to have that
yeah in fact when I got scary movie it I
didn't know at the time that I was
manifesting but there's a woman in La
that I would buy like these little oils
and candles and stuff from and I had
mentioned to her that I had had this
audition and I really wanted this role
and so she had told me go home and sit
and and just imagine what it feels like
when you get the call that you get the
role imagine feeling in your body the
excitement and who you're gonna call and
what you're gonna tell them and she went
through this whole thing and I was like
okay okay I'm gonna do that and I really
did it and I did it all the time and
from the time I first auditioned to the
time I got the role there was four
months in between because they had gone
across the country looking like for the
people for these roles and the whole
time I was just sitting there trying to
manifest because they wanted to give me
a different role and I was like no I
want puffy I don't want another roll I
want Buffy but Buffy was supposed to be
blonde and so Keenan didn't really want
me because he wanted a blonde but then
the the lead role was supposed to be a
brunette so he just swapped us around in
the end but that was the first time I
had worked on manifestation but I didn't
know it was called that I didn't know
what I was doing